Yennefer of Vengerberg comes from nothing, but
her determination and strength make her one
of the most powerful and dangerous mages
in "The Witcher." On the Netflix series,
Yennefer is played by Anya Chalotra, and like
Yennefer in the books, Chalotra has long black
hair. She wears violet contact lenses to
show her elven heritage. The show's Yen
also often wears black and white clothing, the
character's preferred color scheme in the novels.
In "The Witcher" video games, Yennefer is
voiced by Denise Gough and is introduced in
"The Witcher 3: The Wild Hunt." The game version
of Yennefer is a closer match to the character in
the books. Her hair is still black, but it
falls over her shoulders in a mass of dark
curls. She also has violet-colored eyes and
wears her trademark black and white attire.
The video game Yennefer appears to
be some years older than Chalotra,
yet age doesn't mean much when
you are practically immortal.